- That's why I tell everybody
a hundred hours of education
before you buy your first eBay.
Meanwhile,
the second they get hot on it,
they buy 16 things on eBay.
(upbeat music)
You've got your perspective.
(upbeat music) (whoosh)
(audience cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Just wanted to
talk a little sports cards
so that's what we're gonna do.
So if you've got any questions, you know,
I know a lot of people are one O one,
I know a lot of people are two O one.
I know a lot of people are three O one,
just to set up the framework,
but leave comments on the side here.
Just go to everyone.
Please say hello,
say what's up.
And then if you've got questions
please put 'em right into the chat.
I'm glad all of you are here.
And so
basically before we go into it,
just kind of like where I'm at.
Like,
pretty much besides
the way I felt about social media in 2004
or the way I felt about the
internet itself in 1995,
three years ago, I got
that same kind of feeling
in my stomach.
That buzz.
Kinda similar to like,
even within social media
like I felt about Snapchat,
or I felt about TikTok
or when I look at athletes
or just thinking back to like,
just happened here, (murmurs)
somebody should (indistinct)
What's happening in the screen?
Guys, cause I lost everybody.
- One second.
Lemme see.
I don't know why.
- Somebody was able to share
that. Coz I like seeing
the faces.
- Yeah.
- Yeah I wouldn't buy that Joe Burrow card
because the grading
company is bad on that.
Somebody hit something probably.
- Yeah I'm tryna fix--
- Figure out.
- Yeah.
- No worries.
Yeah cause I like having
everybody's faces.
Anyway,
just really excited about the space,
think that there's a lot of
macro trends that led to this.
Thank you Dustin.
I think it's a huge opportunity.
Now at the same token,
the reason I wanted to do
something like this is,
there's a lot of ways to lose money.
For example, that card
that everybody just saw,
if that was somebody's card,
it means that somebody
just got into the game,
bought a Joe Burrow card
but bought it from a grading
company that is like,
I don't even, like
I've spent zero time looking at the bobo
as I would call them trading companies.
But like, I've seen the PGI before.
I haven't done the
homework on when it was,
you know like,
there was a whole year of grading
that happened right after
I got out of the game
in the mid nineties
and I've done my homework on kind of like
the three that I most
care about, which is
PSA, SGC and BGS Beckett.
But just so nobody knows again.
I've put in six months of homework
before I put out my first post of like,
there's something going on here.
And that was three years ago.
So it takes a ton of education.
There's an ungodly amount of mistakes
that I see my friends making
who I've talked to for an hour
by buying a qualifier PSA.
That means something they
think is rated an eight
but the way the PSA company used to do it
it's actually a five
'cause you know, there's just,
there's a billion things.
There's a million different companies.
This is a very deeply
education needed base thing.
On the flip side, I haven't
seen anything like this
from a happiness standpoint in a long time
like my most cynical,
like weather wealth you know,
I think a lot of you know my background.
I have a lot of
very well off friends
and I have a lot of friends
that are very much not well off.
And it's been very fussing to watch
the human dynamics of people
that have gone into this game.
I think that we are in a moment.
I do think it's like any market.
I think there's a lot of things today
that the prices that they are now
in five years are gonna
be way, way, way less
'cause people like to speculate
on up and coming rookies
and just taking high risk.
On the flip side I think
there's some substantially
very smart
investments that are
more interesting to me
than a real estate or a stock sound stock.
If you go into very classic,
kind of very protected places.
So Lou
you're looking at the comment section,
maybe while I look at all the faces
and kinda try to get a vibe.
- [Lou] Yep.
- Maybe you can pick the
question that Dustin will turn on
or maybe you can even
activate the question
since you have more knowledge.
And Dustin you can too
you're getting more
knowledgeable by a second.
But I'm ready to kinda do questions.
The setup is very simple.
This is something that
I did from 1986 to 1994, I loved.
I kind of watched it every day since.
Didn't see anything really meaningful
from a business standpoint, it was fun.
I would always buy a little
here, a little there.
But about three years ago,
three and a half years
ago became obvious to me
what has happened now.
Which is why I started
making content back then.
I'm flattered, I guess
is the way I would say it
that people think like I drove it.
I'm always flattered by
that because I'm like,
I mean do people realize
how big this market is
and how small my audience
is in the scheme of things,
but it's been really interesting.
There's a lot going on.
There's gonna be a lot of happiness had
there's gonna be a lot
of money to be made.
There's gonna be a lot of
money that's gonna be lost
because people are gonna make mistakes
and jumping to conclusions
and lack of education.
I think the two biggest trends
that everybody should pay
attention to while on the edges,
one is what I would call
the contemporary art market.
I think that if you studied
what happened from the 1950s
to today with Andy Warhol's
and Jackson Pollock's
and things of that nature,
there's a scenario where...
By the way, I'm getting bombarded
of people trying to get in
this only holds 500
so if you're just coming
because you wanna say what's up
or what have you, great
but after awhile if you're not interested,
don't just leave and leave this on.
Leave the chats so some people can get in
that are trying to get in.
But I'm pumped that all of you are here.
Contemporary art.
I do think, you know,
Holo first edition Shadowless Charizard,
PSA 10, if there's only 100, 30, 40 of
even though they're a hundred
K today could get crazy.
I think PSA 10 Michael Jordan,
you know, rookie cards
that are 80, 90,000 today
since there's 313 of them,
could get crazy if this
happens the way I think.
What I mean crazy, I mean,
things going from a hundred
thousand to a million a piece
the way that Jackson Pollock's
and Andy Warhol's did.
So on the super high and
the contemporary art thing.
On the low end,
something I see nobody talking about
is we talk about pack breaking
and all this stuff that,
if you don't know what that is on YouTube
people opening up packs.
Pack breaking.
And we talk about it for what it means
for the current hobby.
But I don't think people realize
how many seven, eight and nine year olds
are watching the living
shit out of those videos,
but they're not in the game yet.
There's seven or eight years away
from being in this game.
Kind of,
and so
it's an incredible,
incredible what I would say pipe
to giving you a debate
that the hobby can have much longer legs
than it being just a 12 month or 24 month
kind of thing, (belches)
or at least the hobby is 120 years old.
I'm talking about like these spikes
that we saw in the mid eighties,
late eighties excuse me, early nineties,
the one that we're
living through right now,
the one we saw in the early
seventies, early eighties,
the ones that we saw kind of
in the fifties and sixties,
these have had cycles.
But if you do real economic homework
and look how the card market
has outperformed the S&P 500
on the top 5% premium stuff.
Historically baseball
Mickey Mantle, Stan Musial. (mumbles)
I think that's getting
spread out now into Pokemon,
soccer, basketball.
That's why I've spoken about 95% vintage.
You know, the things I've talked about
have been basically 95% vintage and
or 90% vintage
and five to seven young players
that I think have already
proven enough on the field.
I'm not talking about
a good highlight by Bol
Bol during a scrimmage.
I'm talking two, three years
of performing that get me excited of like,
okay maybe there's something here
outside of Lucca
which you might remember two
years ago or 18 months ago.
I got really excited about
'cause I just saw enough within 10 games
of like, kinda what I need to see.
So that's kind of my macro,
I'd love to get into Q and A.
Let's rock and roll.
Lou if you can--
- [Lou] Do you want me to just ask you
or--
- [Dustin] Yeah (mumbles)
- You two, got it.
- [Lou] Go ahead Dustin.
- [Dustin] William Zimmerman
asked you Gary question,
do you believe in what?
- Hold on.
I wanna put them on if you
can Dust.
- [Dustin] Okay, cool.
can we do that?
- [Dustin] Yep.
- I wanna get some people featured.
- [Dustin] Find them,
hey come here. (sighs)
- I love what's going
on in chat. Everybody,
obviously there'll be so much stuff here,
but like the chat
I think could be more vibrant
than even what I'm doing here.
So if you're trying to learn,
try to pay attention to what's
going on, try in the a chat.
- [Will] Hey Gary, what's up man?
- Hey Will what's good?
- [Will] What's good going on man.
I've been following you for awhile.
It's great to talk.
- Thanks man what's up. (Will mumbles)
Thank you.
- [Will] Few questions.
I got a rising tide theory question
and then I have a sophomore
year card question.
So if somebody's PSA 10 is skyrocketing.
Do you believe in buying the PSA 9?
- Yes.
- [Will] Kind of like
rising tide just raises
all boats type of thing?
- Well my biggest concern is that
kids are gonna get priced out
or people that can't afford
are gonna get priced out.
So I'm excited about the
PSA 8 and nine market.
I even think the eight market
is interesting. ( Will mumbles)
Yeah I mean--
- [Will] Yeah.
- You've seen it right, you've seen it.
So yes, I absolutely believe that.
I also think it hits cross pollination.
Vintage basketball is
finally had its moment.
I'm starting to really
study vintage football
because I'm like, wait a minute.
If Walter Payton and you know,
and Oscar Robertson were kinda comped
but now Oscar's gone up seven X
but Walter stayed in the pocket.
Is that an arbitrage?
- [Will] Yep.
- So yes, I think the rising tide matters.
I think it goes to cross a brand.
We've seen Prizm Lucas go bananas.
And then all of a sudden
you start seeing the hoops
or the optic go--
- [Will] Yep.
- So I think,
yes, I think there's
a lot of that in this.
And I think
for vintage specifically
eight, seven, sixes, fives.
It's hard to get excited
about a PSA 5 modern.
Don't think anybody here
is gonna get excited
but I do think eights is
still an interesting play
and raw we've seen raw.
Forget about even grading.
So yes, I think,
I fully believe in rising duds.
- [Will] One more question.
And then sophomore year cards.
If rookie cards are
getting way too expensive,
for example this guy.
- Not for me.
- [Will] Okay.
- But guess what?
I'm .00000001% of the hobby
and the market.
- [Will] Okay.
- Not for me.
I've never been interested
in year two cards.
- [Will] Gotcha
- You know, my brother
is getting excited about
first championship year card
- [Will] Yeah A.J.
- For basketball players.
Yeah A.J. is like hot on that.
Doesn't go crazy for me.
But it's an interesting--
- [Will] All right. theory.
Historically--
- [Will] If first year cards
get too expensive. (Gary sighs)
- I think if first year
cards get too expensive
if you're looking from
investment standpoint,
you look at alternative
first year cards, right?
I saw Rylan show Wade Topps card.
I started buying a ton
of Bazooka LeBron's.
- [Will] Oh yeah nice.
- You know, when it was
like getting crazy...
Like, so I'm just not
hot on year two cards,
but guess what?
In five years, maybe
that's the fucking jam
and you know, that's cool,
but not for me.
- [Will] Okay cool.
Thank you very much man.
- You got it bro.
Go ahead Dustin.
- [Dustin] Give me one second.
- Yep.
- Henry--
- Mark
I like that Jackie Robinson.
(murmurs)
- [Dustin] Henry Taylor Gill.
- Henry Taylor Gill.
- [Dustin] Come on down.
- All right.
- [Henry] I'm trying to. (Dustin laughs)
- Henry what's good?
- [Henry] Yeah, hey, can you hear me?
Cool
- We can, where are you from?
- [Henry] This is crazy man
I've always wanted to talk to you.
This is so real right now
but my question is do like vintage?
And I know your big into vintage.
I'm big into vintage.
And I bought a George (mumbles)
off your recommendation.
But my question is like going forward.
I know you're big on nostalgia
and I know you're big
on nostalgia for grants.
My question is what happens
when you have like
someone like Bob McAdoo?
Coz I was looking at your
Twitter polls, you've been doing like
who's the greatest ex
or who's the greatest quarterback.
- Who's better amongst these.
I never said, by the way on the record,
'cause I enjoy what I'm doing on Twitter.
Everybody gets mad at me.
They're like, (Henry
chuckles) what about this guy?
I'm like, no, no compare these four.
- [Henry] Yeah.
- And that's like,
these are the four best, but go ahead.
- [Henry] Yeah.
But I have noticed like
the trend with that is
a hundred percent recency bias.
Like you can--
- Correct.
Every single time, it's a
younger crew on Twitter.
And so the more current, great
always outperforms others
within the context.
Which is why I never like live and die
based on those polls.
To be frank,
this is good for all of you to know.
I'm really not doing those polls
for data, for me to buy
cards, I'm doing them
because I'm so in the
fucking card cocoon right now
that I just like start asking
these own questions for me.
And I'm just curious what
other people think too.
So, you know Twitter's data is too dirty
for that to be an indicator
of me to do something business-wise
but it's just kinda literally
when I'm studying population reports
on SGC, BGS and PSA,
watching old videos
or looking for angles
on things that I'm trying to figure out,
it's literally spur of the moment
that I get excited about a poll like that.
And I just put it out for fun.
So listen, I think the thing that
you know, I did a podcast (mumbles)
And the kids were deep in the game
and were very cynical of
when I first came into it
and they got a real lesson
in how deep I'm in this shit right now.
Like I do a lot of homework.
I'm doing a lot of studying.
- [Henry] Yeah, yeah, no
I mean the essence of
my question is basically
in like 20 years time, does
anyone remember who McAdoo is?
Or does anyone remember who
some guy from the seventies was
who maybe wasn't--
- Henry you'll appreciate this now.
They don't remember now.
- [Henry] Yeah exactly.
- Which is why they were under priced.
- [Henry] Yeah, exactly.
But that's a, should I,
would they be worth buying
then on that basis or?
- No, nobody alive right now watched
you know, Hank Greenberg play but
see baseball did all the work for us.
You can do a ton of homework
on what's happening with
the baseball card market
over the last 90 years.
And that's why I'm doing what I'm doing.
Next year is the MBA 75th anniversary.
They're gonna put out the
75 best players of all time,
just like they did on
the 50th anniversary.
That's gonna start
creating all sorts of lists
and all sorts of debates.
All of a sudden
artists Gilmore and Bob McAdoo and George,
they start getting a
little fame out of that,
Bob Lanier and you start
getting a little action right?
And--
- [Henry] Yeah.
- And that's what we'll
see. I mean that ESPN list
is gospel for me, that top 74 players.
Like I look at that list all
the time and I analyze it.
I also think that we
saw with The Last Dance,
the ability for documentaries
to bring a lot of interest
once Lance last dance dominated
in Hollywood right now
there's a billion
basketball documentaries in the making.
And all of a sudden Connie Hawkins
and Oscar Robertson and
Wilt Chamberlain like
you know, that's what happens history.
Plus now you live in a
Spotify, Quibi world.
So you don't need to make a
feature film on Jackie Robinson.
You can make a,
for example, I'm talking to
Dominique Wilkins right now
to do a four-part podcast series.
You know, maybe about him,
maybe about his favorite players.
So like
you're gonna see a lot
of content come out.
That's gonna educate the kids.
Plus it's fun.
It's fun to look back at shit.
And I think more and more
people are gonna do it.
And people are gonna look for angles.
Not only that,
when money starts happening for real,
older money people start coming.
You're about to see a huge influx
of 45, 62,
71, 59 year old businessmen and
women coming into the hobby.
And they do know who Bob
Lanier and McAdoo are.
And when they look the fucking,
fucking Kendrick Nunn PSA 10
are more expensive than Bob McAdoo.
They're gonna buy Bob McAdoo's
- [Henry] Yeah, that's my point.
That's kinda like,
that's what I'm thinking.
Cheers.
- Awesome, cheers.
- [Henry] Right.
- Let's keep it moving.
I appreciate everybody being here.
I'm scrolling through all these screens
seeing all the handsome
and beautiful faces.
I appreciate all of you.
I'm glad you're all here.
And by the way,
take advantage of this moment.
There's a lot of people
in here that are gonna be,
I like that Abel.
I like that GaryVee signed card in there,
I see you sharing that on the screen.
Please, please, please, please
share your Twitter handles
right now in the chat everybody.
Especially if they're linked URLs,
this is an incredible opportunity
for a lot of you to get to know each other
and build friends.
Like literally I expect
at the national in Chicago,
two of you coming up
to my table and be like
we met on that fucking Saturday Zoom.
So like, yes we're here yapping,
but like please,
I see, I love this
watching what's going on with the U...
And by the way, notice how
some people are (mumbles) it,
and some are adding it.
Do the URL
'cause it's easier for
people to just click them
and fucking start following each other.
Coz obviously we're all
in that same wave in here.
let's keep it going Dust.
- [Dustin] Next will be Corey Donovan.
- Corey, get in here.
- [Corey] Hey, what's good Gary?
- Hey Corey.
- [Corey] This is Corey
a.k.a. yamwax on social.
Hey man, I'm looking at this,
this booming cards going
straight into the
football season right now
and with Fantasy Football
and all of that and the new investors
are we gonna see
skill positions like
wide receivers tight ends
running backs, start to
pop week to week or even,
you know, ongoing.
- Yep.
We sure are.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- So for any of the newbies in here,
the thing I was told three years ago
by some of the OGs that I was coming in,
I'm learning, learning, learning.
They're like Gary, the hobby doesn't like
anybody in football besides quarterbacks.
And I was like okay.
But my biggest thing Corey three years ago
was the hobby is gonna get redefined
because if there's
50,000 people in it now,
this is what I was thinking back then.
But there's gonna be 5 million in it.
That 50,000 is a very small percentage.
So what rules are gonna be redefined?
- [Corey] Right.
- And so I think you're gonna
see an explosion fantasy
and gamblers coming into
sports cards this year.
And I think receivers I know Lou,
I'm looking at little Lou on here.
I know he's gone focused on receivers.
Like I'm a big believer
that football is next,
vintage football is my focus,
but I do think that, you know,
I'm not buying A.J. Green's
or Julio Jones',
or even younger guys like Amari Cooper.
But do I think there's real,
real, real money to be made
in like a short term arbitrage?
I do.
And I think that in a long term arbitrage,
they have to be caught.
I think where everybody
gets caught is some,
if you're betting on new kids,
eventually somebody sitting with the back
because to really be worth something
they have to be a top
50 player of all time.
So like,
like I learned this in my teenage years
around Todd Van Poppel.
I bought 4,000 David Justice rookie cards
when older guys
like a very small group
back then was saying
no buy Ernie Banks, buy Clemente.
And I'm like, fuck you old guy.
And that's who I am now.
The action for all these kids
is in the new guys.
And so like--
- [Corey] Like yo,
Gary you go into a card shop.
I recommend anybody do it.
Flip through like early
nineties sports cards
and the early two thousands to
see guys like Clinton Portis.
They're totally forgotten.
So you're right.
You do have to nail the--
- That's right.
- [Corey] Absolute stars.
Think back to all the guys who crushed,
by the way look
basketball is at the height
and look at what a Ray Allen,
or Chris Bosh is doing, nothing.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- And like, those are real guys.
And if this was happening
during the heat's run
Chris Bosh rookies would
be through the roof.
You're gonna get,
a lot of people gonna get
caught with a lot of modern.
But yes I do think in the short term,
but football scares the fuck out of me
because you were perfectly
right about Amari Cooper
and he breaks his fucking
leg in week one. (mumbles)
- [Corey] That could happen.
That can happen
Patrick Mahomes, see
Lamar Jackson too though.
So you know, it's a tough dance.
Football is tough.
- I agree football is tough.
- [Corey] Cool man love it.
- Awesome thank you brother.
Talk to you--
- [Corey] Yep, later.
- [Dustin] Up next will be Adam Rebels.
- [Adam] Hey Gary.
- Adam, how are you bro?
- [Adam] Good how are you?
- Super well, man.
- [Adam] Awesome so I
wanna ask you a question.
I'm from Toronto, I'm a Raptor fan.
We have a stack team and we
have a bunch of young guys
but I feel like they
don't get a lot of press.
- I agree.
- [Adam] They play for the
Raptors and they play in Canada.
- Yep.
- [Adam] Is it worth it
Investing in guys like Pascal, OG.
- I'm obsessed with OG.
- [Adam] Yeah okay.
- Yeah as I believe in his game,
I'm scared that all prison
rookies are expensive.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Like I sat and watched OG
highlights for like four hours.
It's not true.
45 minutes, but it felt like six years.
And then I went to eBay.
I'm like, I'm gonna
steal this fucking kid.
And they were already expensive.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- You know so it's like a
little hard but yeah, no listen,
if somebody's great, they're great.
And don't forget bad for you,
but good for the card investment.
If you know, 80% of those
guys are gonna leave
on the max contract.
- [Adam] Yeah okay.
- You know, I don't want that
for you as a Raptors fan.
I mean, I hate the Raptors
'cause I'm a Knicks fan
but like, for you that sucks.
But you know, those eight,
I would argue that six
out of 10 of those guys
are gonna go to a big market on their...
Yeah you guys are lo...
I mean, Terence Davis, Siakam, OG.
Like those guys are...
Like I think you might
win the title this year.
- [Adam] Yeah, no a hundred percent.
- It's crazy.
I mean fucking (mumbles)
let's state forget it.
You would've moon walked.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Yeah so yeah I don't think,
yes it hurts a little,
but good is good.
And it always works out.
- [Adam] Got it okay.
- Pittsburgh is a small market
but like, you know,
but like if you're good, you're good.
- [Adam] Yeah. Okay no,
that's good to know.
Thank you.
- I mean bro, nobody even
knew where Golden State was
15 years ago.
I was literally being
San Francisco in tech.
All those nerds didn't care about sports
I'd be like, what about the
Warriors? Like what's that?
I'm like Golden State,
they're like, where's that?
While I was in San Francisco.
- [Adam] Right.
- So like if you're good,
good works every time.
- [Adam] Okay all right now
I appreciate that. Thank you.
- You got it. (Adam mumbles)
- [Dustin] Up next will be John Evans.
- [John] Hi Gary.
- What's good John.
- [John] What's going on brother?
- All well.
- [John] Thanks so much
for doing this man.
- Yeah it's fun.
- [John] I'm really
interested in stuff that's on,
you know, you mentioned
doing some recent research
around things that you think
are untapped or undervalued.
I'm curious if there's
anything you'd wanna
share here that you found.
I know
as I've been trying
to kinda leave no stone unturned
I've looked, especially at
the starting lineup sets--
- I love them,
I'm a fan.
- [John] Yeah me too.
- I've been buying,
I only own probably about 50 or 60,
but I've been buying
starting lineup cards.
I've been buying starting lineups
figures to rip the card out.
- [John] Yeah that's what
I've been doing as well.
That one's--
- Yep.
- [John] Especially
interesting just 'cause
it's got really low pop,
in the pop report.
But then also
a lot of the starting lineup collectors
kept them in the packaging.
So even if everything else is--
- There also good looking cards,
especially the early stuff.
- [John] Right.
- Yeah I'm a buyer.
- [John] Okay.
- Lou
might be laughing right now.
Coz I bought a stack of raw
starting lineups at the national last year
I came back, I was all fired up.
He was excited.
He thought I brought back something good.
And then he like made fun
of me, but like I really,
I like them.
Listen, I believe our next half decade,
anything that has low pop
and never had cultural
relevance has a chance.
- [John] Okay.
All right well that's cool.
I felt like a mad scientist
(mumbles)
and then trying to cut them
out in the packaging and--
- I think you're onto something.
I also like,
I also and I really love
branded cards.
- [John] Right.
- You know, I think,
I just really liked the Icee Bear 72 set.
I've been on the record on that.
I see your holding one up right now,
I'm obsessed with that set.
Sugar daddy,
74s, the little ones
you know, 68 Jack in the Box,
San Diego clipper cards.
That weird shit really has my attention.
Because I think--
- [John] Yeah.
- It's extremely rare
and all you need is a little bit
of demand and it gets (indistinct)
- [John] So last question
along those lines.
With the sort of
more obscure stats like the Icee Beer,
do you think along the lines of your
art--
- Yes.
- [John] Arts imitating art thesis
when you have cards
like this that are jumbo
and bigger, I'm thinking so
if this replaces art
and people hang this up I their office--
- I don't think we're gonna hang it up.
But I do think you're gonna see
some display cases built that people can
like hang up their 25 best ones.
So like,
I think the five by seven stuff
like the Interlake Jordan
and all that stuff,
like you may see some stuff happen
but I don't think you take,
I do think bigger cards and smaller cards
again, rules of the old
hobby I think go away.
So I don't think size matters
in any shape or form going forward.
I really don't.
- [John] That's kinda
what I've been wondering.
Coz you have like these
little small stickers
like the 1986 Dr. J.
- Yep.
- [John] But these were
the small Spanish stickers.
And then you have like these jumbo cards
and I'm wondering if one or the other
is gonna be better than just your regular?
- One man's point of view.
It could be totally wrong.
I think it plays out that
neither size matters.
- [John] Okay, all right.
- But I think
a lot of people in the hobby
have thought standard cards only
and that's where there's an arbitrage.
- [John] Awesome, thank you so much man,
for what you're doing
for the hobby, very cool.
- Thank you, John.
- [Lou] We're just
getting a lot of questions
about like how to start.
So I don't know if you want
to just make like a nice--
- Yeah.
- [Lou] Statement for them?
- Yeah Lou, may there's a
lot of starters in here.
Can you link
like 50 times in a row in my chat,
that URL that you guys made on my blog
that has all the links that we think
is this 10 hour starter kit
to get all the rules down, thank you.
For all the really, really noobs,
which you know I was just
three and a half years ago
but I had like decade of experience
but you needed to get
refreshed on all the new rules.
We'll put a bunch of things here
please feel free to share it out
and things of that nature.
And Lou, because you're
so sharp on the ship
since Dustin's picking questions
why don't you read
the chat pretty aggressively Lou
and then maybe jump in with some questions
in between quickfire questions
that seem to be common
or you know--
- [Lou] He's pretty much doing that.
And then he's just--
- Okay, awesome.
- [Lou] Sending me names.
- Awesome so Lou,
feel free to jump in
occasionally and just,
if you see something that's interesting,
you just ask the question on behalf.
Go ahead Dustin.
- [Dustin] Liam Wasserman.
- Liam.
- [Liam] What's up Gary?
- What's good bro?
- [Liam] I heard two questions.
So what do you think,
like why do you think base cards
are beginning to outsell
certain autographs?
- Cost of entry.
There's so many more people into this now,
but at first,
I mean this is expensive shit Liam
and not everybody,
a lot of people are
collecting, not just flipping
and it's hard to buy a
silver for 6,000 bucks
you know or a one O one
or a Kaboom 10 or
so I think whenever the
hobby is very popular,
when there's a lot of demand,
baseball always do better.
What you grew up with,
it sounds like by you asking that question
which is you were in it before this boom?
- [Liam] Yeah, I was,
I've been in it for about
seven or eight years.
- Perfect, the demand was much lower--
- [Liam] Right.
- So that demand group
didn't want the basis
'cause there was a lot of supply.
They went after the one
of 100, the one of one,
got it?
- [Liam] Yes.
- So as demand grows,
the base grows with it.
- [Liam] And then I also had
another question about like,
how do you feel like
celebrities in the game?
So like you, Steve Aoki,
Mark Wahlberg are all of
big accounts that are
starting to put out sports cards.
How do you think that's
gonna affect the market?
- Oh, I think that's
what the next wave is.
I think, you know, Wahlberg
is on a different level
and Aoki is a different level
than me for that matter too.
Like I've always said this the last year.
You've probably heard it.
I'm like you guys think I'm fucking
wait till you see what's gonna happen.
I mean, I think we're--
- [Liam] Right. moments away
from the coolest people doing it.
Top 10 rappers, top 10 athletes
and then it's gonna be fucking game over.
Game (mumbles)
- [Liam] Yeah cause I've seen,
like you on your podcast,
like telling who was it?
Like Serge Ibaka to invest in cards.
- Again Surge is like, he
hit me up the other day,
Surge by the way to the gentlemen,
I don't see him.
Toronto kids, Surge told
me about Terance Davis.
That's why I started
really looking at him.
Again Surge is a great solid NBA player,
but I'm like talking like,
Dwayne Wade and DaBaby
and Gunna and TI and Tyga
and fucking, you know like,
like real fame.
- [Liam] Yeah but then you,
but then you have to think
like maybe cards might start being,
start to get too expensive
for people like me.
- Of course.
- [Liam] I'm 18.
- [Liam] I'm not going to
be able to afford all this
while I'm in college.
- Of course.
But two things will happen.
One since you've been in it seven years
that's gonna escalate so much
that you're gonna have more capital
if you deplete it--
- [Liam] Right.
- If you're not just holding.
Two, it will adjust
and you'll look at nines and eights
or like me,
me and others are looking
for starting lineups,
we are like
you grew up. And most of
the people I talked to
that have been in it for 10 years or more,
you grew up in an era where it was tiny.
So it was concentrated.
- [Liam] Yeah.
- PSA 10, you know limited cards.
Right?
- [Liam] Yeah.
- What you're about to watch happen
is the complete expansion of something
that is gonna make 59 things important.
Not just one.
- [Liam] Coz I know personally
I've been all modern
but I'm starting to look into vintage.
So like my PC,
I'm a Cleveland fan.
I go to Ohio State.
So like,
I'm looking into a 58 tops, Jim Brown,
that I wanna buy and eighty's
(mumbles) Jordan's--
- Yeah bro and by the way bro,
do me a favor, buy a 58
Jim Brown immediately.
Because that one's about
to get bananas bananas.
- [Liam] Yeah there's,
I'm looking into a couple of low grade
just 'cause that's what I can afford but--
- I respect that.
I would tell you
one of the ways that a lot
of smart kids are gonna win
is they're gonna buy and sell
very hot things,
like a Tatum or Mitchell
or Michael Porter jr.
Take profits and go into
more scarce vintage.
That's where I see kids
really amassing true wealth in this era.
- [Liam] Yeah coz I
wanna look into vintages
more of a longterm hold
while I'm in my four years of college
just to keep one for now--
- Liam.
But I think everybody's starting to learn.
Everyone is like Gary vintage
doesn't go up as fast.
And they were all telling me that.
They're like Gary,
the new stuff goes so fast.
I'm like cool.
You don't understand
the second vintage demand rises.
There's no fucking inventory.
- [Liam] Right.
- I was buying PSA fucking eight
Dr.J's a year ago for 700 bucks.
Now they're fucking five, 6,000,
seven to eight, 9,000.
- [Liam] Right.
- Right, and I saw,
John Snyder was driving,
put up thumbs up.
So you know,
I'm taking that as a contextual guy.
Who's been in it for a while
or understands these pointers sound like
either he sees it or he's lived it.
Listen, I lived this already.
It was called 1986 to 1994.
What did I do?
The same mistake I'm trying to tell
a lot of kids not to make,
which is I got excited about
everything that was
happening of the moment.
Now you should still do that.
That's why people gamble.
That's why people watch sports.
I get it
but if you're really trying to build like,
I wanna buy a house with this one day,
I wanna start a career like,
it is about supply and demand.
And the vintage stuff is such
an important place to look at.
- [Liam] Yeah.
- By the way, back to Ohio
State. Braxton Miller hit me up.
- [Liam] Really?
- A week ago and said I wanna
get in. So I'm talking to him.
- [Liam] Yeah, I'm on campus right now.
I'm a first year so...
- Enjoy, all right, let's keep it moving.
I haven't looked into blockchain.
I saw the blockchain
question over and over.
I haven't really looked at blockchain.
Like my blockchain is very simple.
Like I believe in blockchain technology.
In 2015 I bought some Bitcoin
after a funny debate night on
at South by Southwest.
I did extremely well,
but I have not been active in it.
Right now I actually see the
physical nature of the cards
acting like contemporary art.
But blockchain is a technology
that will all be affected
by through the years
and there'll be plenty of opportunity.
It's just not where I'm
putting my energy right now.
- [Lou] A lot of people are asking about
like soccer, vintage soccer.
- Obsessed.
- [Lou] Yeah I think--
- I'll make it very simple
obsessed period.
- [Lou] I think one of the, for me
and that's a question--
- And by the way
back to clarity,
Lou you know this as well as I do,
what do I have?
25 cards.
I have very little inventory.
- [Lou] Yeah but I think
something that I would
wanna hear about is like,
when it comes to,
I think a lot of people are looking for
when it comes to modern stuff.
People are looking for Prizm.
They're looking for Topps Chrome.
Coz that's stuff they know
when you get into vintage soccer,
especially it's like the
most random shit ever,
in terms of like--
- Hand cut,
auto magazines, (mumbles)
stickers in Europe.
- [Lou] Yeah and like, what is
the brand called?
Like no one knows what
the actual card is so...
- I think all of it is in play.
The grading companies did it for you,
you know and I'm seeing Josh,
share one of his cards on screen.
like and Lou,
you know, what's fun, Lou?
Is you've been with me.
And guys, Lou who's on
the screen right now
or just as talking.
You know, he's my admin
but I've known him since he was six.
We're jet fans together,
his dad and I are great friends.
Like three years ago when I was like,
yo, we're doing this.
He kinda laughed about it
but he was into it and helped me,
Lou you know this.
I was about the weird
stuff from the beginning,
the handcuffs, the 52 Wheaties
were the first things I was buying.
You were laughing you know.
- [Lou] 52 Wheaties like those
random shit I've ever seen in my life.
- Right so like,
like I'm not scared by any of the random
50, 60, 70s soccer stuff.
All of it is interesting to me.
As you know Lou,
the one thing I haven't
gotten into is the postcards.
I'm a little, that's the,
literally the only thing I haven't bought
but like all of it I think has to be,
Lou here's why and everybody's watching.
- [Lou] And bottle cups.
- Yes, I did built,
I did bid on an actual soda bottle cap
on eBay and everybody made
fun of me the other day.
I think the hobby will evolve
its point of view on things.
But if it's graded and
that means kind of official
I think all of it is
employed to be debated of.
Pele has got like seven different cards
that are debated as the rookie card.
Ali all this stuff,
like I think all of it's gonna be debated.
Jerry P I'm gonna make sure
that card's worth a lot
of money for you one day.
Yeah.
So I think soccer is,
there's a lot to learn.
You know, I've started by
educating myself on who
the 50 greatest players are
since I didn't grow up
really being hardcore
doing a lot of homework.
It's the global sport.
Basketball is emerging as the
new and next global sport,
which is why I'm so bullish on it.
Obviously I understand it a lot better.
The World Cup is gonna be super exciting.
You know,
you also have a potential
generational talent
if it stays healthy with Mbappe
happening at the same time.
So there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on on soccer.
Soccer and Pokemon are very important
to all of this conversation
because they are gateway drugs
to people that don't like the
big four sports in America.
And so I'm watching a lot of
people get into a lot of things
because Pokemon and
soccer are getting them in
and then that gets them
John, I love your emotions.
I guess your agreeing
with me, John Slater.
I think Pokemon and soccer
are getting people that would
have never considered cards
back in the day in
and then they're bleeding
into football and basketball
and other things the same way.
I mean, I'm watching basketball.
Only kids get into Juan Soto
and Fernando Telechea Junior.
It's just ha...
I'm gonna say it one more time.
I am very good at pattern recognition.
It is why I've predicted
so many things right.
It's why I'm successful along
with some other dynamics
but it is one of my great skills.
I'd seen these patterns before
I lived them in 1985 and 86.
And it's just happening again.
But it's happening with the internet.
It's happening with YouTube pack breaking,
it's happening on the back
of the 86 to 93 year old
where I became obsessed,
but now I have money.
So there's like,
so the 5,000, 50,000, 500,000 others.
So you're getting a different wave
because when it happened 86 to 93,
the parents of that era,
they weren't the generation
that was in love with cards
when they were kids.
So they were like what?
They were like kind of ah!
What you're seeing is kids
dragging parents in,
parents dragging kids in.
It's a bigger dynamic this time.
It is.
- [Lou] Next is Colin--
- Colin.
- [Lou] (mumbles) sorry I
can't pronounce it. (chuckles)
- [Colin] Hey Gary pleasure to be on.
- Nice to have you on Colin.
- [Colin] So my question had to do with,
so I've been preaching to my friends
saying, you know what?
Get on this, get on this, it's early.
And like kinda everyone I've talked to
says that again I know you're into
super into vintage and stuff.
And I've kind of been
focused on modern right now
and moving that money into vintage.
But everyone I've talked to thinks that
it's like gambling,
like you're betting on players to win.
And I see a lot of people
making quick money like that.
I just wondering what
your thoughts are on?
- It is gambling.
- [Colin] Yeah so you would
say straight gambling too.
- I wouldn't say it's straight gambling
because the reason I started
yelling three years ago
and the people that jumped on
I knew the whole thing was gonna go up.
So it was almost like everything is gone.
Look, if you're losing
money in cards right now,
turn off the computer and
never go into business again.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- Like, that's what
happens when it explodes.
Now we're starting to
enter the next phase,
where it is more I mean,
do you see what people are
paying for national treasure,
RPAs of kids that have
that 90% of those kids
are not gonna make it.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- Now, if they flip it
quickly it's day trading
versus buying Apple stock for five years.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- I'm playing this the way
I play the stock market.
I buy seven, 12 things
and I sit on it forever.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- I'm not day trading,
90% of this room right now.
And the Twitter and
social are day trading.
That's fine.
I don't get to judge how one plays it.
But that is gambling.
Now I think when you
do it with Devin Booker
and Acuna versus Michael Porter Jr.
And fucking Jasson Dominguez
it's a different level of gambling.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- Right?
- [Colin] Yeah, yeah.
- Right, so I think when you're betting on
16 year old prospects and Bowman,
you are completely
rolling your fucking dice.
I think when you watch a
season like Acuna last year
and the fucking pedigree,
you're not gambling as much.
Now you're in Derrick
Rose gambling territory
which means,
which means everything could be right.
And we're all right about Acuna
and (mumbles) up but--
- [Colin] Yeah.
- But Acuna could become
Bo Jackson get hurt
and not happen.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- I lived through Bo Jackson.
I lived through Petty Hardaway.
I lived through Grant Hill.
I lived through that.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- You know, what's fun about vintage?
Jerry West is always gonna be the logo.
Jerry West is always gonna be a 12 time
OG. Jerry West is always gonna be the guy
that fucking traded Vlade
Divac for fucking Kobe Bryant.
Jerry West is always
gonna be one of the iconic
old white guys that could play.
Jerry West is going nowhere.
- [Colin] Yeah longterm,
you can't go wrong.
- You can go unbelievably wrong
with every single,
I mean you know how much money
potentially is gonna be lost on Zion?
- [Colin] Oh yeah, no I--
- Now Zion could go on to be,
you know, fucking LeBron.
And but the potential,
I promise you this
between Zion, John Moran, Jasson Dominguez
like there's some real money
gonna be lost in the Sierra.
Maybe not by the people
that are sitting now
'cause they're flipping it.
But somebody is gonna
be sitting with the bag.
- [Colin] Yeah, just
straight collection Zion.
- And I don't want to
be sitting with the bag.
I'm buying things forever.
- [Colin] Okay.
- And that's it.
- [Colin] Yeah I know.
Well, thank you very much.
- You got it, brother.
- [Lou] Next is Tommy Hayes.
- Zion could be Shawn Kemp.
That's a great example.
Do you understand if this
was the NBA final season
with Shawn of the Sonics
versus the fucking Bulls
how expensive Gary Payton
and Shawn Kemp rookie
cards would be right now?
Like kids are not thinking
now they're day trading
which is okay.
I'm telling you,
I haven't figured out
the piece of content yet,
but at some point I'm
definitely gonna put out.
Hey, kids be a great day trader,
take 30, 50% off the rack
and put it into something that's long term
and just keep playing that game.
I think that could be
because then they've got
something for themselves one day.
It's also why I love Pokemon.
Pikachu is not gonna
tear his ACL. (chuckles)
Let's keep it going.
- [Lou] I just, I unmuted
someone but not sure who was.
- [Tommy] Right here.
- I'm just gonna get
some shout outs.
Antonio (mumbles) what's good.
Eric Rodriguez, Brian Shaughnessy.
What's up?
- [Lou] Go ahead.
- [Tommy] Hey Gary, this is Tommy.
- Tommy what's good?
- [Tommy] I had a question about
I've seen a big trend on
vintage basketball, football
baseball, reprints,
and then people going, getting them PSA'd
and then putting a Walter Payton rookie
for $1,300 out there.
That's a reprint.
- Education, education education.
- [Tommy] Yeah so am just saying,
you see these people like,
you know just keep on doing it
or you know just--
- I hope not.
My hope Tommy is that
somebody here in this room
that doesn't know how they
wanna enter this industry
decides to start a Twitter account
or a social media account
that lists everybody who's
trying to trick people
with qualifiers and reprints
and becomes one of the
five biggest accounts
in the whole sports card hobby
because everybody references it
and it stops people
from being fucked faces.
- [Tommy] Yeah, I agree.
- I think that's a, by the way,
for anybody who's kind of clever
and wants to do something
a little different.
I think that would be a monster account.
But Tommy that,
Tommy, that's why I tell everybody
a hundred hours of education
before you buy your first eBay.
Meanwhile, the second they get hot on it,
they buy 16 things on eBay
and buy a fucking PSA 8 Qualifier
and get ripped off.
They buy a reprint and get ripped off.
They buy a bullshit grading company,
you know, BCG.
- [Tommy] Yeah.
- And like people make fucking
mistakes, it pisses me off.
- [Tommy] I see these clown bags out here
doing this and I'm just like,
you're gonna push away too
many people from the industry
and piss too many people off.
- The good news is
if I feel like the reason I'm
being loud around education
is I'm hoping the next people
that have big audiences pick up on that.
And hopefully that will be a big
and we all gotta keep pushing that
and you know,
I can't control trimming
and things of that nature.
Like that gets hard.
That's like FBI shit.
But like the common stuff of like,
you know, reprints or fucking,
or the qualifiers really
trick people heavy Tommy.
- [Tommy] Yeah.
- The PSA sub qualifiers.
People are getting ripped off heavy.
- [Tommy] Oh yeah.
Thanks man.
- Thank you brother.
Thank you man.
- [Lou] A lot of people are asking about
the future of UFC trading cards, yes.
- I don't know.
Some of you even know VaynerSports
is now in the UFC game.
We're repping some pretty legit dudes.
We've got a main event tonight
and I'm literally starting my process
of UFC homework this weekend I think.
So I believe in UFC,
I think UFC is a really good sport.
I haven't done any homework,
have no clue on population.
I'm only starting to get my education.
I'm bigger.
I was historically a bigger boxing fan
than I was UFC, but I've always dabbled.
But now that we're in
the business, I'm heavy.
And so I have a lot more
to say in the next year,
but if you know UFC,
it's definitely somewhere to look at
because boxing cards, golfing
cards, tennis cards like when,
and again, I'm looking at
a lot of faces in here.
Even some less older cats in here,
we're gonna see another entire cycle.
This is gonna be this era.
And what is it gonna be?
12 months, 49 months, 62 months.
I'm not fucking no Stromness.
I have no clue how long this happens
but what I can tell you
is it's gonna happen.
It's already happened.
Like I said, it would, we're in it.
It's gonna have a run.
And then whatever it is,
the global economy, something else
just general fatigue of
everybody being hot on it
together for five years.
And it gets boring, like
every other thing in life.
And then there'll be a dip.
And then again seven, 12, 19 years later,
they'll come right back.
This has been 120 years in the making.
So that's why I want
you sitting on Jordan's
and you know and LeBron's
and Dr. J's and Walter Payton's
not Michael Porter Jr
and Michael Porter might turn out to be
but like the gambling
is so high on modern.
- [Lou] Jackson.
- [Jackson] Hey Gary?
- What's good Jackson?
- [Jackson] Hey, so I had a question about
what do you think is better
investment for baseball,
either prospect cards or the rookie cards?
Like I have this Bowman,
Acuna prospect card.
I don't know if you'd rather have--
(murmurs)
- Yeah.
It felt like for a long time
Bowman was winning the day,
the hobby had Bowman
but we've seen a major surge
on Topps first appearance
in series two or update.
And I think it will
continue to evolve Jackson.
I think you play the arbitragers.
It might end up being
heritage in seven years
and that was the right arm.
So I think,
I think you hedge,
you don't pop commit to anything.
It was very clear that it was
Bowman three years ago to me
when I did my backlog homework.
Topps has closed the gap quite a bit
in the last 18 months,
but I think both of them are quite sound.
The problem is right.
Like you look at Eloy Jiminez,
who's having a great year now, right?
What hurts Bowman a little bit
is that he's in his Cubs uniform
and he's a white sock.
And you think about those
kinda dynamics a little bit,
a lot of these minor
league guys switcheroo
versus when they hit as a rookie
and are awesomely locked in
for quite a while on that team.
So there's a little bit of that, right?
I think one of the reasons
you know, Moses Malone for example,
is under rated
is 'cause he played for
like nine different teams
but had he played in one
place for one time, right?
I think about like those things.
I always think about Wade Boggs,
probably under priced
'cause he became a Yankee.
And so like Boston fans
can't go there, right?
Maybe even (indistinct) for that reason
though I think he has two great fan bases
that are less direct rivals.
So these are all the things
that run through my fucking head.
- [Jackson] Okay thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Lou] I would also say
on the Topps, Bowman thing,
G like (mumbles) is an example of a guy
who popped off this year, like his bowman,
his bowman is still, you know, $800
and his top series too is only like 260.
So like the Bowman still does carry
a pretty big premium for a lot of guys.
- I think so but I think we've
seen Topps close the gap--
- [Lou] I agree with you.
- And you've seen--
- [Lou] I'm on the side of,
I think Topps is better
but that's just my personal opinion.
- You know, it's like,
yeah, I think I think they'll evolve.
You know, I think that,
I think it's gonna be
interesting to watch evolve.
I do you think Topps will
continue to close the gap
intuitively I think so.
I also think it's a price point.
That's a little more affordable
to the youngsters.
I also think Topps.
And (indistinct) when
we did stat with them,
I yelled at them.
I'm like make your regular product good.
They finally did this year
with like some parallels and some autos.
Otherwise it's boring as shit.
- [Lou] Gary.
- I think we can block the
sexo sexo anal. (Lou chuckles)
- [Lou] Okay.
- I think he's not,
I think he's not looking to bring value.
- [Lou] Not a lot of
sports card questions.
- Yeah I don't think sexo sex.
I don't know if that's like,
you know, I don't know if I like penis.
I like penis is like (Lou chuckles)
some hot, some hot pitcher
and you know Dominican
Republican right now,
but I'm gonna lean towards
Brian (mumbles) is not bringing value.
Alright, let's keep it going.
By the way biggest ROI,
biggest reason I jumped in here.
Is if you're following me
wanting to be in here
and you're about the subject matter,
there's a substantially strong situation
that you wanna be, that you
can be friends with each other.
So after this is done,
please go to Twitter
and use the hashtag.
Thatwasfungv.
This way you can all find each other
and maybe get into combos,
follow, make some trades
buy from each other,
whatever you'd like to do.
So let's get that hashtag in there.
Thatwasfungv.
Let's get a couple more
in here real quick.
- [Lou] Jerry.
- [Jerry] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Jerry] Can you hear me?
- I can.
- [Jerry] Alright great.
So I had a question.
I got like $2,000 into the sports cards
and I'd like to say,
I've got some pretty big stuff.
I've got like a Zion silver 10 here.
I've got a load of Mbappe's
I mean, I was buying 'em
when you said to buy 'em.
I got 'em at 52 bucks a piece.
I still had to pay 20
bucks to get 'em graded.
But at what point do you cash out?
And what I mean by that is,
do I sell one card to
get all the money back
and have a little safety?
So it's all free money or--
- Yes.
- [Jerry] Okay.
- That's always a good idea.
Now the problem is,
you know you may sell something
that gets you all your
money back at 3000 bucks.
And then watch it go to 11,000
and be like, what the fuck?
So the only time to cash out,
is at the moment that was
the right time to cash out
and nobody can tell you that.
- [Jerry] Okay, well, so
I'm a Dave Ramsey nut.
I literally just use the
stimulus money that I got.
Cause I was like well,
it's free money, you know,
might as well go for it.
You know, how do you decide
what to sell out?
Cause I've got like five Mbappes.
You know I've got this one
that I'm keeping forever
because you know--
- Thank you brother.
- [Jerry] You're just the real OG.
Like literally.
- Jerry, you're a part
of a new grade of people
that, you know,
what's really wild about
the people that came in
through my funnel
is the stuff that I pushed.
Yannis, Luca, Mbappe went so crazy
that a lot of people made a lot mon...
While the hobby was like
trying to figure out if I was full of shit
or bad or good.
But my audience ended up doing extremely
well on those bets, LeBron, Chrome.
And so you know,
you've got to decide, is
this something you love?
Is this something interesting to you?
Is this something that
you are learning about?
Or was it something
that you believed in me?
You decide, you believed in,
you know, turning your
stimulus into something
and now you're sitting here.
You might be the kinda guy
that should just sell right
now and that's amazing.
You made a lot of money
but if you're seeing like,
wait a minute, I like Pokemon.
I like sports or I like something
and I wanna learn more.
It depends on how much more
you want to get educated.
Your answer to Mbappe brother,
is doing homework on Mbappe.
Understanding that he may
go to the Premier League.
And what?
Understanding that the
World Cup is in Qatar
in the winter of 20,
like education is how
you make these decisions.
I have a huge advantage
that I live the life I live now
where I actually DM with
Juan Soto and Fernando Tatis
and like, get to know these kids
and then decide, are they a knucklehead
or are they trying to work
at all times to become great.
And then that helps me make decisions.
It's all data and information.
- [Jerry] Well honestly,
so the whole reason why I
honestly got into the sports cards
was to learn how to build a YouTube page.
And I would really like to come work for
you or Dave Ramsey as a content creator.
This right here is my favorite card.
- What is it? (mumbles)
- [Jerry] This was the
only credit.
It was a credit card that I had.
I cut it in half to do
the Dave Ramsey stuff.
- I love that shit.
good for you.
- [Jerry] Debt free.
I was gonna send it off to PSA,
but I really appreciate your time.
I don't (chuckles) feel greater,
but Jerry you're on the right path.
So keep making content, by the way
you were probably the perfect guy
to get deeply educated
and make the social media account
that Tommy and I were just talking about,
which is the one that
you need probably 200 hours of education.
So you don't, so you have a good account,
but it's posting like auctions
that are trying to trick people
like who knows,
maybe that's your thing.
- [Jerry] Yeah,
well I was gonna say
one way to tell everybody
the safest way to get into sports cards.
I've just been going out to Walmart
and using free capital that I had.
They put out 600 bucks worth of mosaic.
I tripled my money in 10 days on eBay.
And I mean that's
you know it's insane.
- And by the way,
and that flip has spurred a
lot of emotion in the hobby
because they're mad about the people
that are buying everything.
And that's on Walmart to try to figure out
if they have to start limiting.
And this is all human
and economic dynamics
everybody has to figure out
what works for them.
People, you know,
people say that's not right.
And I'm like look,
I struggled to tell another
man how to feed their family.
Right? If it's not illegal--
- [Jerry] Yeah.
- It's very hard to tell,
you know, like everyone,
people in control,
Paninis in control of their business.
Walmart and (indistinct)
control their business.
Everybody here is in
control of their business.
So there's a million ways to get educated
and there's a million ways to play it.
But I think good, honest, kindness
and real education and trying
to do it the right way.
There's so many ways to win in this
and it's enormously fun and
it makes watching sports fun.
And first, you know, look at me.
I'm 95% vintage.
I love sports,
but I just think there's so much,
I get so much fun in doing research
and figuring out that
there was a cookie company
that made a 1954 Hank Aaron card.
And I think that's weird and cool.
And because I think it's gonna go more art
on the super high end.
I think some of these
cards that are $4,000
that are weird that nobody wants,
could end up being $3 million.
I'm not kidding.
- [Jerry] Yeah, yeah, I mean you know--
- There's a million ways to play
or you wanna do Patrick Mahomes
'cause you think he's gonna win
four of the next five super bowls.
Mazel tov to you.
- [Jerry] Well hey man,
I really appreciate you
so much Gary.
- Happy to it brother.
- [Jerry] Like you are the best man.
I've read your books.
Listen to you daily man.
Just keep up the good work.
Thank you so much man.
- Thank you so much.
Sneak one or two more in here.
- [Lou] Cody Caro.
- [Cody] Hey Gary.
- Hey, what's good?
- [Cody] What's up?
So funny story.
You actually, you and Lou
actually bought a plane ticket
for me to come to the national.
- I remember.
- [Cody] Unfortunately
that got canceled.
- I remember.
- [Cody] But hopefully
we'll be able to meet soon.
So I got a question about card breaks.
- By the way, that's the
other thing that I really love
about this hobby right?
Like, I think,
you know, I've tried to bring
a ton of kindness to it.
You know, again, I'm not confused
and a lot of you are in it
and I know what people think about me
or did think about me,
they're like, there's so many
you know like,
like buying somebody,
a plane ticket to come to the national
is like the karma that I love living on.
And it's like really fun.
And I think for a lot of you,
if you're doing really
well, made a lot of money,
like helping a kid get into it
or stopping somebody from making mistakes.
Maybe instead of posting
all your flexes of sports cards every day,
posting an article that teaches somebody
how not to buy a qualifier.
Like, there's a lot of ways to give back.
- [Cody] Yeah, of course.
- Go ahead my friend.
- [Cody] So my question
is about card breaks.
They're getting more and more popular now
and it seems like
almost everybody wants to get into it.
- Yeah, it's fun.
- [Cody] Yeah, of course.
That's why I got into it myself.
So I've been doing it since February.
I've been trying to grow
a community around it.
Not just for them to you
know, join my breaks,
but just around the hobby in general,
how can I kinda like
stand out as a new card breaker.
- That's gonna be completely
based on your skills.
This was the question
everybody asked me on Twitter
and YouTube in 2006, 'cause
I was blowing up there.
There like how do I stand out?
And my answer was be good.
And being good comes in a million forms.
You're attractive.
That's good, that works.
Your funny, that works.
You're deeply educational.
You're entertaining.
You came up with a random
idea that was different
than anybody else had
ever done it that way.
It's all the same shit brother.
- [Cody] Cool yeah,
I've actually tried--
- But in the beginning.
In the beginning.
Lemme give you a qui...
Lemme give everybody a
good piece of advice.
If you wanna a card break,
make your first 15 episodes
totally different to see what's resonating
and what fits good for you.
Don't pick your format.
Try 10 different formats
in the first 10 episodes.
- [Cody] Oh yeah, that
makes complete sense.
When I started out,
I tried out a bunch of
different types of heartbreaks.
I tried like,
somebody gave me an idea for
a blind auction card break.
I was like, sure lemme try it.
Like I haven't seen anybody do it.
Lemme just try it.
But I've also been
trying to like give back
since like I've learned a bunch of stuff
and you know it's really tough
to become a card breaker.
I've actually started creating a guide.
I have a discord where
people could come in,
they could host their own card breaks
to try it out, to see if they like it.
They could ask questions,
just all that sort of stuff.
I even got--
- I love it.
- [Cody] Pokemon braking.
Keep going brother.
Keep going.
- [Cody] Thanks man, appreciate it.
- Take care.
- [Cody] Take care.
- [Lou] Let's go.
- [Diana] Hello.
- Hey Lou.
Hello Lou, can you get a rapid fire,
maybe four or five of the questions
that you thought popped--
- [Lou] Yep I'm getting it right now.
- And who's up Dustin?
- [Dustin] Diana.
I figured we should--
- Hi Diana?
- [Dustin] Change up a little. (chuckles)
(Diana laughs)
- [Diana] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Diana] Hi Gary.
I've read all your books.
I'm a huge fan this is so amazing.
(Diana mumbles)
- Thank you.
- [Diana] I'm a mother
and I'm from, I'm 39 so I'm old.
And so my boyfriend
has a bunch of Jordans,
so very happy about that,
but I'm also interested in Pokemon
because ever since Dustin show that big,
big ass stuff toy.
And also because yes,
he can't tear his ACL
and I have two boys,
I have a six and seven year old,
and I wanna do it as a
family thing. (Gray mumbles)
And investment long term as well.
And the whole contemporary art angle
also has me really intrigued.
So I want it,
not only for fun,
but investment for our family.
- This is fun and a hobby
and a family event that
can make you money.
- [Diana] Yeah exactly.
- Getting into skiing costs money.
- [Diana] Yeah.
- Becoming a Disney family
costs money.
- [Diana] Exactly.
- And like, this is crazy that way.
I think you're on it.
And I think Pokemon
is as safe as it gets, (Diana mumbles)
but you have to get
uncomfortably educated.
- [Diana] Okay, I can do that.
- Like 100 hours of watching
video and reading, 100.
- [Diana] Oh, I'm used to
uncomfortable. (Diana giggles)
- Good.
But I think you're on it.
And I think it's gonna be great.
- [Diana] Aside from your guide
which I will get into your
guide sharing the link.
Is there anything else that
in terms of Pokemon, so I
could really focus (mumbles)
- Ready, ready for this Diana,
get off right now, go on Twitter.
Thatwasfungv.
We're gonna all do that--
- [Diana] Okay.
- Hashtag it's gonna be
my last thing I say here
before we leave.
- [Diana] Okay.
- Thatwasfungv.
And you could just say
anybody helped me with Pokemon.
There's probably 670 people
in here that can really help.
- [Diana] Oh perfect I love it.
Thank you so much Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Diana] See you soon.
I'll be onto the GaryVee soon,
I promise I'm gonna
bug you guys. (mumbles)
- I can't wait.
- [Diana] Bye.
- Lou, bye.
Lou.
- [Lou] Yep.
So someone asked about thicker cards.
So like national treasures, Nawar,
what do you think about those?
As opposed to the base stuff?
- Again, I don't think size matters.
I'm obsessively scared of Nawar
because they're black and
they can't grade well.
So I think there's just
an incredibly difficult thing to collect,
but if you love collecting raw
and you're not worried about
quitting, they're amazing.
So it just, it comes
down to how you see it.
- [Lou] Do you think 61 Fleer
is too expensive right now?
- I think 61 Fleer Basketball
is grossly under priced right now
even though it's gone up five to 10 X.
- [Lou] Someone was
talking about vintage QBs.
They said their uncles
didn't test the (indistinct)
And they're wondering about
investing at vintage QBs.
- I think vintage QB's
are wildly under priced.
- [Lou] Lamar versus Mahomes prison base.
- Lamar versus Mahomes,
I think Mahomes will have a better career
but anybody can get hurt at any time.
- [Lou] And then thoughts on soccer?
We talked about it a little bit.
Basketball talked about a little, it's--
- Everybody come in with your question
that you wanna ask right now
we'll do a whole rapid thing
and Lou will just keep
reading his favorite one so
ask for detailed questions.
- [Lou] Lagging
severely over here.
- No worries.
- [Lou] I'll try.
(Lou hamming)
Listen to card talk.
I'm gonna, plug card talk real quick.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- [Lou] Card talk pod 1:37 p.m.
Talk about cards every week.
Myself, Tyler Schmidt from team GaryVee
and Ryan Johnson, card collector too.
We'd have like interviews every week.
We've done Pokemon.
We've done vintage stuff.
We're gonna have Gary on soon.
And me and him, are just gonna argue about
vintage cards for like an hour straight.
It's gonna be great.
- I see Garbage Pail Kids in the chat.
I haven't gotten into it yet.
The window of Garbage Pail Kids
was like an 18 month phenomenon.
And I don't think that was
long enough for a phenomenon
for it to be like a crazy thing.
But I can see it tripling during this era
because we still have millions of people
that are potentially
coming into this hobby
or investment thing.
So I think everything even
right now has real potential
but I don't think that's
the most potential.
And on the downturn, I
think a Pikachu Red Cheeks
PSA 10 is better than an Adam Bomb PSA 10.
- [Lou] What do you think about grading
from like the inevitability
of digitized grading?
In like AI for grade?
- I can't wait.
I can't wait for the
machine to be invented.
I'm trying to get Elon Musk to invent it.
And just make it,
and then this way,
all the debating and scare goes away,
but that would make things vulnerable
because if you have a PSA 10 at $40,000
and it comes back a new machine nine
people gonna be fucked up,
but that's,
there's risk in everything.
- [Lou] I have a little
spinning wheel here.
So I don't know if Dustin
you had seen newer stuff, but I can't.
- [Dustin] What do you think
about the current LeBron James
and Kevin Durant PSA 9 rookies.
- LeBron James and Kevin Durant.
Yeah, I think both,
I think Kevin Durant has the potential
to be the most interesting of them all
because I think people
quickly forgot that he was really
the best basketball player
in the world (chuckles)
like when the day he got hurt.
And so I think Durant
any place in New York.
I think Kevin Durant is
extremely interesting.
High risk, some hot, excuse me.
High upside some risk, depending on how,
but his game,
the way he plays
is not reliant on his injury.
And so I just think,
and I think he's very chip on shoulder.
I'm very bullish on Durant.
Lou you know, this I've bought
maybe more Durant than anything.
I'm very bullish on him.
And I think PSA 9 is
incredibly interesting category
as things get expensive.
I even think PSA 8,
for the not ultra modern,
but the modern call it the 2006, 2010 back
is even an interesting debate.
- [Dustin] Someone asked about,
I can't find it now but--
- SGC over PSA?
You know, it's interesting,
Andrew you probably know
I'm very fond of SGC.
I think they're extremely
difficult on grading.
I know there's that one viral post where
a 10 SGC got six PSA
but like you see that all
the time in every direction.
Like I think
SGC is tough grading,
I like the black case personally.
I know that's completely
subjective opinion.
Everybody likes different cases.
I think there's three companies.
I think it was PSA, BGS and SJC.
And I submit a lot,
probably more than the norm to SGC
and I get mad about it
because I get back bad grades (laughs)
but I just like their cases.
- [Dustin] Sports cars
depends on the clear skills,
but what are you, what about Pokemon?
What are their,
what makes them I guess,
favorite than someone else?
The community of Pokemon people
getting excited about characters
or new original programming,
kind of like Star Wars.
If Pokemon starts doing
content on Netflix around Squirtle,
just on a six part series on that,
that's gonna build up demand.
And so future behavior with the IP
is gonna change the outcome.
Just like in the comic book world
nobody gave a fuck about Black Panther.
And then all of a sudden
they know movie is coming
and everybody does.
Same thing with Pokemon.
Over the next 30 years things will pop up
whether it's toys,
whether it's cards,
whether it's a video game,
whether it's a movie,
whether it's a mini series on Spotify,
that will feature a specific Pokemon.
And that might change
the market dramatically.
All right I gotta go.
I hope everybody enjoyed.
Hope this brought you some value.
Hope everybody is super well,
thank you for being a part of this.
To continue this incredible community
please go to Twitter right now.
#thatwasfungv.
Thatwasfungv.
Use that hashtag.
Lemme just put it in here.
So everybody, there's no mistaking it.
#thatwasfungv.
There you go.
And I hope everybody's well,
good luck. (Gary Smooches)
See you. (electric whoosh)
Hey, everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so much.
So humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch, but
time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that,
there's plenty form where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.